pendant qu'un discuter cette question il
y a quelques années et n'avait pas
l'intention de rouvrir ce débat
le premier ministre peut-il ignorer un
jugement de la cour suprême
vérification faite il y a des précédents
dans sa décision de 1988 décriminalisant
l'avortement
la cour suprême avait recommandé au
parlement d'adopter une loi pour
encadrer ce droit par rapport à ceux du
foetus
or rien n'a été fait et jusqu'à ce jour
il n'y a aucune loi sur l'avortement au
canada
devant ce vide juridique les médecins se
fie à leur code déontologique la santé
le bien-être de la patiente et en leurs
préoccupations
la cour peut comme elle l'a fait l'an
dernier sur la prostitution donner un an
gouvernement pour réécrire sa loi
stephen harper s'est plié à cette
décision dans le cas de l'aide médicale
à mourir la décision devrait être rendue
à quelques mois des prochaines élections
générales
si la cour émet des instructions il est
peu probable que le gouvernement puisse
agir avant le prochain scrutin
au québec la seule province à avoir
légiféré sur la question l'adoption de
la loi mourir dans la dignité a pris
quatre ans et demi
et si la cour décide que le suicide
assisté est illégal
rien ne changera ici denis martin chabot
radio canada montréal